we are bringing together a panel of
experts to answer your questions about
the corona virus and the massive
economic stimulus package CBS News
medical contributors that's dr. David
Eggers there they are dr. Tara Narula
are with us and Jill Schlesinger is here
- she's our CBS News business analyst to
answer all your questions David we're
going to start with you first
it comes from Laura from California
you've got a twofer
she asked can you can you get tested to
see if you may have it already and then
someone named Gail at the Stephen
Colbert set wants to know if you already
have the virus and you've been diagnosed
how do you know when it's safe to
re-enter society start with Laura first
please huh all right so that's our dream
is to have a test in the blood to see
who had the virus and who made an immune
response other countries have it it's
out in China it's at in some of Europe
hopefully we will have it in the next
week or so and that's critical to know
if you can go back because what we think
is that if you have immune proteins if
you have antibodies in the blood which
this test will show is that you cannot
get the virus again at least for a short
term we don't know long term because the
virus has only been around since
December and how do you know if you have
it when you can reenter society if
you've been diagnosed i am i forgot that
someone named Gail is the question yes
it is three days after symptoms are
totally gone and seven days at least
since the beginning of symptoms so if
you meet those two criteria you can go
out all right all right we've got a
question now from a viewer named Dave
this is for our Tara Narula and the
question is is there any proof that the
corona virus can be caught by pets can
it go to our pets a lot of people want
to know about pets and so there's no
evidence to date to suggest that pets
can either be a source of infection or
that they can contract Kovan 19 that
being said there really is a lack of
data and research in this area so the
CDC says if you are suspected to have
coded 19 or you've tested positive you
really do want to maintain distance from
your pet the same way that you would
from humans so you want to avoid the
kissing snuggling petting that you love
to do and if there's someone else in
your home that can help take care of
your pet you want to ask them to help
out
it must be you that doesn't make sure
you wash your hands before and after you
interact with your pet I've got a
question for Jill which comes from a
viewer named Elaine who wants to know
does the $1,200 relief check that's
being sent to individuals include
retired seniors Jill absolutely it does
so even if the only source of income is
Social Security you will get this check
as long as you fall below that's $75,000
threshold and even if you don't file
taxes don't worry the government will
access your information through the
Social Security system so seniors you
two will be getting checks Jill I've got
another one for you too it comes from
Debbie she says she's been out of work
for two weeks she wants to know when
will people see their unemployment money
yeah I'm hearing from a lot of people
around the states usually states have a
one-week waiting period they're
encouraged to waive that but because of
these flood of claims we saw over three
million in a week that isn't stopping up
the system Debbie I'm hopeful that you
get this in the coming week so two to
three weeks is what we're hearing from
the the crowded states where there are
tons of claims all right David you know
the weather is getting warmer every day
and one viewer here on Instagram asks
are we learning anything from studies
that look at the weather and virus
effects not yet it's just too new the
virus began in December I mean the hope
is that other viruses can go away as
temperature goes up so we don't know
what this won't but we do know our
behavior changes and as temperature goes
up you're out of doors the UV sunlight
degrades the virus the virus is not
alive and so will temperature itself get
rid of these particles we don't know I
hope all right this is for this is this
is for Tara comes from a viewer named
Julie who's 64 years old has asthma
wants to know about non-essential doctor
visits she asked specifically is it safe
to go to a chiropractor Tara well so
Julie's over 60 and she has asthma both
of which are going to put her at
increased risk so you want to look at
who you are what your vulnerabilities
are but also what is the service or the
visit for
certainly if it's something that's
urgent you know your doctor or the
health professional may want to see you
if it is non urgent most doctors offices
are rescheduling and pushing pushing
patient visits out at least 45 days or
so this is a great point where
telehealth or telemedicine can be useful
lots of doctors offices are doing it for
more non urgent issues Jill another one
for you this is Denise on Facebook who
says so workers who are laid off due to
the corona virus will they get their
full payment will they get their full
pay through the unemployment Department
no they probably will not so they're
going to be two tiers of unemployment
one is through your state of residence
and that goes as much as 26 weeks and
that usually covers somewhere between 40
to 50 percent again very state specific
and then the government program that
will tack on 13 weeks to whatever the
maximum is in your state and will also
provide you with $600 a week for four
months through July so you've got to
check with your state probably will end
up at maybe 70 or 80 percent of your pay
prior to the virus Jill well we have you
there's a viewer named Doug who's got a
question that I share as well if you get
this $1,200 a stimulus check you have to
pay taxes on that no you do not and
that's great news right because that
would be sort of a little weird double
whammy there's one little issue though
because you're you're basing your check
on your adjusted gross income line eight
beyond your tax return if you have not
filed yet for 2019 they're gonna go look
at your 2018 returns the only adjustment
that could be made is if your income
really changes maybe goes higher in 2019
I don't think that's going to be a
problem for most of the people who are
involved here Anthony
oh sorry I thought you guys were picking
that up this comes this is for David and
it comes from Diana on Facebook who asks
since this is an illness that attacks
the lungs if you had the pneumonia
vaccine does that provide some
protection against the severe symptoms
great question the answer is no the
pneumonia vaccine is against a
particular bacteria that can cause
pneumonia this virus is totally separate
while they both cause pneumonia
the vaccine will not affect your
response to the virus at all and you're
still is likely to get pneumonia
unfortunately and Terra this comes from
Vanessa on us on Facebook she wants to
know I keep seeing posts about people
making masks for the medical
professionals is this actually okay and
approved well so the surgical mass in
the n95 s are the ones that are really
certified and regulated and that's
because they're tested for how they fit
with the materials that are used how
permeable they are what kind of a
barrier they are that being said in a
crisis situation which we are in and
we're hearing so much from the frontline
workers about how they lack personal
protective equipment any sort of a
barrier even if it's a cloth mask may
help prevent those large droplets from
entering the nose or the mouth of the
healthcare worker so there are some
hospitals in this country that are
accepting donations others are not so
you need to check in the local area
where you live but certainly it is
inspiring to see how many people have
stepped up to try to help Tara I've got
a question well you can stick with you
here and it's one that's come up in my
household we're all washing our hands
constantly it's winter time we're dry or
skins dry and we get these kind of
cracks and it's not only are they
painful but my question is when you have
cracks on your hand is that make you are
you more susceptible to touching
something and have the virus get inside
you well it's not really that the virus
would get in through the skin so that's
not really a portal of entry but we know
that your hands if they touch droplets
and then you touch your face
you can certainly spread it that way to
the nose or the mouth or the eyes so you
definitely want to be careful about
where you're putting your hands and
where you're touching which is why we
say hands
the neck if possible I know it's
difficult but really try David I want to
follow up on the stay home stay safe
because a lot of people more and more
people who are self quarantine is it
okay to go outside to just walk around
the park is that safe because somebody
told me no you shouldn't even go outside
because you can pick it up on in the air
you can pick it up on your feet when
you're walking around what is the truth
about that yeah it's okay to go outside
UV sunlight does degrade the virus you
need to maintain social distance there's
talk in New York of closing streets yeah
people make it easier so they can
actually walk in the street and have
that social distance but we're gonna go
stir-crazy if we're sitting in a room
staring at four walls can you put your
shoes safely somebody said you can pick
it up on your shoes walking in the
street is that true I can't imagine that
the virus is going to live and then be
able to carry through in your shoes that
being said you can always leave your
shoes at the door if you're worried
I know it's honestly everybody's so on
edge the slightest little thing just
sort of set you off that's why it's good
to know the facts and nothing but a lot
of good information there from the three
of you David Tara and Jill thank you
very much